[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Michel COG Hélène buzetti
bonsoir bonsoir la journée la plus
longue qui ne se termine pas
alors
bon premier tour de table sur cette
victoire de la CAC je vais vous faire
entendre monsieur Legault qui est encore
aujourd'hui
a tenu attendre la main au Québécois de
toute origine a-t-il dit comme si les
centaines besoin vraiment de jeter des
ponts on écoute on revient
c'est certain que c'est toujours délicat
de parler d'immigration mais on doit
ensemble avec les communautés
culturelles avec les nouveaux arrivants
avec les anglophones arrêter de déclin
du français faire la promotion du
français au Québec et je pense qu'on est
capable de se parler donc on trouvait
des façons que je puisse rencontrer
entre autres différentes communautés et
puis de voir comment on peut ensemble
travailler à protéger le français puis à
ce qui se sent bien au Québec
bon parce que pour ceux qui viennent
d'arriver là qui était peut-être
ailleurs dans un autre pays Montréal n'a
pas voté comme le reste du Québec on va
le voir sur la carte Montréal bon les
libéraux qui ont gardé leur château fort
ils sont repliés et la CAQ tout autour
des gains à Laval des guerres
montérégies des gains partout
Chantal monsieur Legault c'est clair et
puis on l'a vu hier ensemble
il sent le besoin de rétablir des ponts
des ponts qui le lui-même un peu saboter
beaucoup merci pendant la campagne
électorale c'est pas les communautés
culturelles donc il parle tout à coup
les anglophones qui ont saboté les ponts
ou les Montréalais c'est monsieur
Legault qui
de des premières entrevues de sa
campagne a commencé à parler des
Montréalais qui a regardé de haut les
Québécois qui est finalement est arrivée
avec les immigrants et les qui sont
associés à la violence pour avoir son
ministre d'immigration qui nous apprend
qui travaille pas en plus alors ouais il
y a du travail à faire mais ça va
prendre plus que une journée et demie de
belles paroles pour préparer les dégâts
Michel en tout cas c'est magnifique qui
veulent réparer les dégâts
je vais le réparer les dégâts mais le
discours ne pas changer c'est encore
écouter ce qu'il a dit ce matin c'est
encore les immigrants qui sont
responsables de la de la perte de
pouvoir du Québec du français au Québec
qui dit que c'est ça est-ce que on a
fait ce qu'il fallait pour les francisés
et ces Français ont moins de place au
Québec c'est leur faute c'est pas une
façon de commencer dialogue ça alors
c'est le groupe veut faire ça qu'on met
tout sur la table y compris l'attitude
de la majorité compris parce que la
majorité parce qu'il faut faire la
translation Hélène comment vous avez
décodé depuis 24 heures là les discours
moi je trouve qu'il y a quand même une
leçon pour nous tous les commentateurs
ça fait quelques semaines qu'on parle
des gafs de monsieur Legault sur la
question de l'immigration ou des
questions
identitaires au sens plus large et
visiblement ce que l'on constate comme
des gaffes ne pas été considérés comme
tel pour un grand nombre de Québécois
même que il y a eu une prime allure
c'est à dire que Monsieur LEGO a obtenu
non seulement plus de votes qu'à la
dernière élection mais plus de votes que
ce que le laisser prédire les résultats
de sondage qui laissent croire moi que
vers la fin les gens ont aimé ce qu'ils
ont entendu ils n'ont pas nécessairement
répondu comme tel ou sondage mais ils
ont coché comme tel alors il y a
évidemment une déconnexion avec la carte
électorale entre Montréal et le reste du
Québec mais moi je pense que cette
déconnexion elle prend racine dans ces
questions là que les élites
montréalaises médiatique qui sont basés
beaucoup à Montréal
ne comprennent pas pas nécessairement ne
voit pas et il y a cette cette faussée
là qui est propre à tous les pays
occidentaux où vous avez une espèce de
déconnexion grandissante en ce qu'on
pourrait appeler les peuples nationaux
et les élites plutôt urbaines et c'est
ça qui se déploie aujourd'hui au Québec
aussi
la déconnexion on veut pas
nécessairement vouloir voter ou
approuver des gens qui la rendent encore
plus évidentes ou encore moins réparable
1 2 de dire que ça marche c'est pas un
argument de dire que ça marche ce serait
comme de dire mais Donald Trump qui a
raison il y a quand même des votes donc
tout le monde qui disent qu'il dit c'est
divisible c'est dommageable pour le
tissu social c'est des analystes qui se
trompent parce que ça fonctionne le
texte de ce qui fonctionne quand les
questions tissu sociales c'est pas si ça
donne des votes
c'est aussi à terme ça va faire des
enfants forts et dans ce cas-ci le
discours de Monsieur Lego s'il pensait
que ça a fait des enfants forts il y
aurait pas passé la soirée d'hier la
journée d'aujourd'hui à dire à peu près
le contraire de ce qui a projeté comme
message pendant six semaines ça peut
être efficace d'accord allez-y Hélène
mais ça peut être efficace il faut pas
simplement récompenser les gens qui
attisent les feux la question n'est pas
là mais il faut pas non plus
nier le fait que certains mépris face à
un discours identitaire un certain déni
de légitimité de ce discours là alimente
aussi la division je pense qu'il y a
deux solitudes deux clans qui ne veulent
pas se parler et je pense que cette
élection-là nous dit il faut davantage
séparer les Montréalais et le reste du
reste du Québec en disant c'est pas
montréalais qui vont décider bon déjà
à loin
[Musique]
Hélène conclusion là-dessus je veux
défendre les chiffres de Monsieur boulet
qui était archifaux mais je parlais plus
généralement de ce discours sur
l'immigration de masse qui fait peur à
une certaine une certaine un certain
nombre de Québécois qui trouve que
peut-être qu'ils se sont ils se sentent
bousculés dans leur identité bousculé
dans leur langue ce n'est pas en leur
disant qu'ils sont des édentés et des
imbéciles qu'on va les apaiser il faut
écouter cette malaise et il faut essayer
de rebâtir justement des ponts justement
en ne s'en voyant pas seulement des
tomates par la tête
on en a d'ailleurs parlé je pense qu'on
le soulignait au panel souvent que ces
cinq qu'on puisse parler d'immigration
même si tout passait par les seuils puis
c'est un peu le résultat les seuils puis
pas le début mais n'empêche c'est un
débat qui a le droit d'avoir lieu c'est
ce que vous soulignez là
la question c'est est-ce que à chaque
fois qu'on en parle si on donne
l'impression qu'ils sont responsables
d'un problème tout le temps est-ce qu'on
fait pas porter un succès par ailleurs
dans des endroits il y en avait pas
besoin de succès parce qu'il est très
très populaire sur des gens qui sont ici
puis qui travaillent qui ont rien
demandé c'est un peu ça peut ça que
qu'on a entendu moi c'est ça que je
reçois comme courriel des gens
effectivement
violence c'est monsieur Legault qui a
fait un lien entre l'immigration et les
dangers pour le tissu social ça c'est
vraiment pas là il le dit alors un
moment donné il faut aussi qui accepte
que ces paroles soient pas
nécessairement acceptées par tout le
monde comme étant assez bien correct
parce que tout le monde qui pense de
même parce que Hélène
je veux passer à d'autres sujets mais je
veux quand même le chef du Parti
québécois lui proposa encore dans d'en
accueillir moins que monsieur Legault et
jamais il y a eu une phrase qu'on a
souligné comme étant
provocatrice vis-à-vis l'immigration
c'est ça qui est particulier dans le
débat non oui bien sûr et je suis pas en
train de dire que tout ce que Monsieur
LEGO a dit
voilà
mais oui effectivement mais il reste que
la vous êtes on a beaucoup débattu du
seuil mais c'est aussi parce que seuil
et francisation ne semble être qu'à peu
près les deux paramètres sur lesquels on
a un peu le droit de discuter de
l'immigration aussi pas pour rien qu'il
y a beaucoup de prudence aussi autour de
ce sujet parce que c'est très sensible
parce que c'est délicat et bon
visiblement monsieur Legault est pas
super habile dans les nuances mais c'est
vrai que ce sujet-là bien on a libéré un
peu la parole on a pu en parler un peu
plus mais c'est ça reste un tabou au
Québec comme au Canada d'ailleurs en
fait peut-être
parce qu'on parle de vraiment qui existe
qui travaille 80 heures par semaine qui
était là pendant un pandémie au salaire
minimum qui sont fait dire par le
ministre l'immigration qui ne
travaillaient pas
ça d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui est passé par la tête de
Monsieur bouli
j'en parlais à Bernard drinville tout à
l'heure en entrevue puis bon lui dit que
c'est une erreur ok on avance il reste 9
les bon on victoire néanmoins puis je
vais quand même vous entendre là-dessus
gigantesque 90 c'est énorme faut
remonter à Bourassa en 1989 Michel C je
suis pas obligé de plus vieux mais je
pensais à vous quand on parle des
résultats antérieurs c'était pas du tout
ça mais non mais vous avez un souvenir
des résultats aussi
c'est une grosse victoire Michel
c'est une très grosse victoire et quand
on parle de reformer le système
électoral ça aurait été une grosse
victoire si on avait eu la
proportionnelle aussi quatre parties
ancien 40% des voies qui ont aucun des
autres parties qui dépassent 15 ça peut
pas être autrement le problème de notre
système électoral c'est que c'est un
système qui marche bien quand il y a
deux parties ou à la rigueur un
troisième petit parti quand il y a cinq
parties et donc quatre de position qui
se divise le même vote qui est à peu
près le même score ça donne des
distorsions majeures comme ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui je vais montrer le tableau
pendant que je donne la parole à Chantal
sur le sur ce débat qui a été relancé le
monsieur Legault a fermé la porte
derrière jamais été ouverte dans son cas
mais oui elle a été ouverte il y a 4 ans
mais je veux dire il leur permet
aujourd'hui très clairement ça c'est ce
que ça aurait donné là avec un une
portion de proportionnelle je vous évite
les détails 75 pour la CAC 16 pour les
libéraux 14 pour Québec solidaire donc
les libéraux auraient perdu Québec
solidaire monté PQ grosses augmentation
et conservateur de 0 à 10 c'est quand
même c'est quand même deux planètes
différentes c'est ce que les gens disent
quand il y a quand les gens expliquent
une distorsion si on prend en compte de
la du pourcentage de vote devrait votes
dans tous les contes c'est ce que ça
aurait donné est-ce que c'est fermé
il faut noter que ça là ça gouvernement
majoritaire de la casse c'est
majoritaire
on peut en parler jusqu'à demain matin
mais ça changera rien le fera jamais bon
d'abord
vous avez parlé d'âge et de souvenirs
moi je trouve que le mode de scrutin le
dos large aujourd'hui il y a le dollar
en particulier dans le discours du PQ
pourquoi parce que je suis assez vieille
pour me souvenir même si j'étais pas
bien à l'époque du Parti québécois qui
avait promis si il formait un
gouvernement de changer le mode de
scrutin
alors aujourd'hui alors que le Parti
québécois a quand même récolté comme la
partie libérale le pire score de son
histoire
c'est tout à coup le mode de scrutin qui
prend toute la place je suis d'accord il
y a des distorsions je ne crois pas une
seconde qu'on va changer de mode de
scrutin je ne crois pas que le Parti
libéral à terme va embarquer là-dedans
et même si Dominique Anglade voulait je
pense pas que son leadership ils sont
livrés
mais néanmoins quelque part ça devient
une belle excuse pour pas faire
l'autopsie de la réalité Hélène est-ce
que c'est un débat qui va quelque part
non
ça n'aura pas lieu et d'abord je dirais
il faut faire un petit peu attention
avec les chiffres qu'on qu'on propose
s'il y avait eu la proportionnelle le
grand problème de des réformes du mode
de scrutin c'est que il y a des dizaines
voire même des centaines de propositions
différentes on a fait un calcul mais ça
pourrait être plein d'autres calculs ça
dépend on met beaucoup de
proportionnelle moins de proportionnelle
proportionnelle régional etc et c'est
loin
ça c'est le scénario que j'ai montré
c'est le scénario qui avait été déposé
et ce qu'il faut aussi se rappeler moi
ça me frappe en tout cas à quel point
c'est souvent quand ce sont les
progressistes qui perdent l'élection qui
a ce genre de débat là je vous
rappellerai
que les conservateurs ont plus de voix
que les libéraux et pourtant ils ne
forment pas le gouvernement et j'ai pas
entendu beaucoup de gens déplorés que ça
ne soit pas andrewshire ou eren qui soit
devenu le premier ministre il faut quand
même aussi remettre les choses en
contexte très bien donc ça c'est le sur
le mot de la journée distorsion libéraux
pékistes on le dit plancher historique
dans les deux cas particuliers
trois députés je vais Arsenault disait
on va on va rebâtir
là c'est le jeu des attentes comme
beaucoup de gens disent peut-être à
rester un peut-être zéro à trois on se
dit sur une bonne soirée mais c'est
difficile à trois aussi Michel coger
soyons clairs
n'aurait probablement pas gagné dans la
cabine lorrain si la député solidaire a
été pris à piquer des dépliades dans une
boîte à lettres ça fait une différence
aussi alors sinon il y aurait eu les
Îles de la Madeleine qui sont quand même
un côté atypique puis il y aurait eu le
droit de Matane qui continue d'être le
roi de mental mais et là on dirait bon
Dieu parce que il est vraiment mal pris
cela dit effectivement le PQ on croyait
complètement mort grâce à Monsieur
septoplamand donc qui a fait une
campagne différente et qui a fait une
très bonne campagne peut penser vivre un
autre jour et ça ce n'est pas rien quand
on sait ce qu'on attendait en début de 4
et c'était vous avez vous souligner une
bonne campagne peut amener des points ça
c'est la preuve Hélène
oui vous l'avez dit à ces jeux des
attentes on célèbre ces trois députés
parce qu'on pensait vraiment qui allait
finir à zéro ils ont quand même par
rapport à la dernière élection si on
regarde juste le nombre de votes obtenu
là ils ont perdu à peu près 13 % de leur
vote alors c'est pas une bonne élection
mais quand même l'élection du chef
change complètement la donne si le
monsieur Saint-Pierre Paul Mondon
n'avait pas été élu la situation serait
vraiment différente aujourd'hui c'est un
chef qui a démontré sa capacité donc ils
peuvent bâtir à partir de cette personne
et lui sera là donc à l'Assemblée
nationale Shazam un petit mot sur le PQ
avant de passer à Québec solidaire
en fait je crois moi que le particulier
va trouver un droit de parole à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que j'ai
l'impression que le Parti libéral n'aura
pas le choix que de dire oui avec le
pourcentage de votre inférieur 20 plus
députés il faut se garder une petite
Jane et partager son temps et donc
l'élection de Paul
saint-pierre-la-mont-d'or ça me dérange
pas dans quelle circonstance c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour le Parti
québécois mais ça change pas quand même
la donne qui a x nombre de parties sur
la glace et que si dans quatre ans les
Québécois sont fatigués de la CAQ plus
que du Canada ils vont chercher un parti
susceptible de battre la carte puis avec
trois députés c'est pas évident que ça
va être le Parti québécois
Québec solidaire Gabriel a dos Dubois
l'a reconnu puis il le dit hier soir et
je suis déçu on aurait lui-même voulait
mettait la barre plus haute ils sont
dans les centres-villes enfin si on
travaille le milieu urbain disons Hélène
tour de table
comment vous voyez la suite des choses
actuelles mais évidemment si ils sont
sûrement déçus mais je ne pense pas que
c'est une élection
inutile pour eux ni même que ça témoigne
nécessairement d'un plafonnement dans le
sens où je crois que c'était une
élection d'enracinement pour qui QS il a
vraiment atteint ce parti un stade où il
fait partie du paysage il est normalisé
aux yeux de plusieurs et c'est une étape
de franchi importante qui pourrait
porter des fruits plus tard ceci dit il
y a encore clairement une très
importante réticence face au programme
de QS le programme économique beaucoup
voient ce parti orange comme une menace
rouge un péril rouge et si Québec
solidaire continue son œuvre de
recentrage et de modération il y a de
beaux jours devant lui devant lui ce
parti mais mais ça dépend vraiment des
prochaines étapes qu'est-ce quel genre
de modération
seront prêts à faire genre aller
chercher deux trois fiscalistes là pour
mettre de l'ordre en plus dans les
propositions fiscales je veux je veux
aller sur le Parti conservateur avec
zéro le comment vous croyez Chantal que
ça va se passer dans les prochains mois
parce que Monsieur duel disait tout à
l'heure je voudrais qu'il me fasse une
petite place pour que je fasse des
conférences de près on pense pas que ça
va arriver derrière monsieur le bois
déjà dit non comment vous voyez la suite
des choses pour ce mouvement qu'il a
créé
quatre ans c'est vraiment long quand on
a pas de place à l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai vu aussi que Monsieur Duhem se
disait je vais débaucher des députés de
la carte sans doute des gens qui vont se
sentir négligés parce qu'ils sont pas
dans le conseil des ministres etc
peut-être mais ça arrive pas
nécessairement demain matin et en plus
avec les résultats qu'il a eu c'est à
dire incapable de faire lire des députés
ou se faire élire lui-même c'est moins
tentant pour un député de la carte qui
aime son poste à l'Assemblée nationale
de se dire je vais devenir le
conservateur de service pour ouvrir les
portes d'assemblée nationale à Monsieur
Dream alors peut-être que son meilleur
moment là
l'éclat
l'éclaircie c'était maintenant et que ça
a passé ouais rapidement Hélène et
Michel Hélène oui je pense je suis
d'accord là-dessus je pense que c'était
l'élection de la première mais
malheureusement aussi peut-être de la
dernière chance 4 heures c'est long bien
une grosse peuvent arriver mais je suis
pas certaine qu'il va être capable de
maintenir cette colère qui était le
moteur de son mouvement qui faisait
suite à la pandémie je ne vois pas
comment ça va se maintenir
je suis d'accord avec l'analyse de mes
deux collègues je mets je vais ajouter
une chose
il y a pas c'est pas dans une loi c'est
nulle part dit que on peut pas faire une
conférence de presse sur la colline
parlementaire et on a vu comment il y a
déconner quand celui la possibilité de
le faire à cause de de la même façon
si décide d'aller non pas à l'édifice du
Parlement difficile la tribune de la
presse il peut facilement faire des
conférences de presse là il y a rien qui
s'y oppose et un moment donné ça il y a
13 % des voix il est un parti politique
n'ont pas reconnu à l'Assemblée
nationale mais reconnu comme parti
politique par le directeur des élections
peut-être qu'on peut jouer avec ces
concepts là un peu mais dire non tu as
pas le droit même de mettre le pied là
c'est un peu fort puis ça se regarde
merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne fin de
soirée bon dodo pour ceux qui vont les
faire dodo merci beaucoup au revoir à
très bientôt